[Music]
the new Godzilla 2019 is merely a
sculpture of the 2014 version the
legendary Godzilla's phase is blocky
its neck is broad and has shot like
gills making this the first Godzilla
designed to feature gills his teeth are
relatively small around 16 number but
each canine tube is about 4 feet long
two feet wide and not nearly as
straightly line up as in previous
Godzilla designs the head and the neck
seem to lean forward more and the
nostrils are more separate being on
opposite sides of the snout making him
more reptilian like instead of the more
mammalian fashion of being close
together in front compared to past
designs during production it was
expected that changes would be made to
the Godzilla design but just how big of
a change the expectations were very
small like cuts and scars from his
previous encounters with the Muto's but
nobody expected this big of a change so
let's dive in and spot where we can find
right off the bat we can see that the
body mass of g19 is bigger than a g4 tip
team Godzilla in 2014 is confirmed to be
355 feet tall and with a length that
stretches 550 feet and 4 inches and
weighs about 90,000 tons whereas the
Godzilla 2019 is 393 feet tall 582 feet
long and weighs 99,000 634 tons next SDI
color of Godzilla in the 2014 version
the eyes are golden yellow while in the
Godzilla 2019 version the eye color
changes when he uses his atomic breath
becoming bright blue and actually
emitting light and later it becomes
bright orange red when he turned into
super burning Godzilla coming to the
back Godzilla 2014 dorsal plates are
smaller than the previous designs but
they still retain the co maple leaf
shape although straighter and very sharp
creating a more jagged look when rising
from the water
Godzilla 2019 s dose of plates are
definitely much bigger and much more
classic in design
even the largest dorsal plates on June
19th back definitely resembles that of
the dose of plates from the original 54
version it is very interesting that the
creature designers took some inspiration
from past designs for the jostle plates
while keeping it close to the 2014
design the new design features more
protrusions the three large central dose
of plates running from midway down his
back are the same shape as the original
Godzilla dorsal plates when viewed more
closely we can see that the claws of the
G 19 Stowe's are also longer while his
skin became rougher and texture asked
with the atomic breath we can already
see that the G 19 atomic breath is much
larger and brighter compared to the 14th
version it gives off a radiance that is
powerful enough to even push Ghidorah a
few steps back and tumble him down on
his back and if it puzzled enough to
easily attract moth to a flame when
comparing to 2014 version when his
atomic Brad was able to start and kill
the female Muto
it wasn't really that impressive now we
can truly see how powerful Godzilla's
atomic breath can really be while coming
to the tail it has also changed the tail
for the G 19 is elongated and rounded
like the tail from the designs of the
90s even the way the tail arcs when
lifted out of the water in the 2000 90th
design it's telling that it's heavy in
weight as well the 2014 version had a
much shorter and lighter tail even the
tip of the fourteenth tail had a pointed
tip at the end that can be used as a
whip when he defended himself from the
male Muto to me they are both awesome
looking in every way I just want to show
and compare their differences and
similarities between them and the old
Godzilla designs what are your thoughts
on the matter did you spot anything that
I may have missed well let me know in
the comments your thoughts on the new
design make sure to stay up to date by
subscribing to our channel for more
reviews and discussion on all kaiju
related topics